who's actually ramming a human's head
into a wooden cabinet and hi I'm Jimmy
Fallon and these are five of my favorite
comedies of all time even though I've so
many favorites I this is more than this
so I really really want to do this again
but right now I'm gonna narrow it down
to five just so you can pick five films
one of these will really make you laugh
Animal House is a classic based off of a
National Lampoon article about college
life I love personally John Belushi
I love the casting in this because
everyone looks like they're probably 50
years old to be honest and yet they're
in college but at the time that's the
way things worked I mean grease had John
Travolta so you're like really does he
look like a high school kid like Sam you
swear to god they can't believe you know
I'm you know he's going through a
midlife crisis now but everybody was
cast perfectly in that movie there's so
many subtle jokes it makes you cheer you
see a young Kevin Bacon makes it a cameo
in that there's great music there's so
many quotable lines and it is definitely
a go-to comedy for me Animal House well
done bridesmaids if you have not seen it
yet then you probably don't live on
earth but if you do live on earth and
haven't seen it you should check it out
it is one of the more modern of the
comedy choices I picked because Kristen
Wiig will just will just teach you a
lesson and show you how to be funny
she's unbelievable in this movie if you
didn't think Kristen it could be funnier
then get ready for Melissa McCarthy
because she hits you over the head with
a cinder block of comedy it is
unbelievably well written well acted
well directed bridesmaids one of my favs
airplane at this so many quotable scenes
but one is there's a little boy comes up
to the cockpit of the airplane and Peter
Graves is the pilot and he goes uh you
ever been in a cockpit before Joey and
he goes no no sir I've never been on a
plane before have you ever seen a grown
man naked and the kid acts perfectly
acts like you didn't hear what he said
really and then the questions get
crazier is like Joey you ever been in
Turkish prison and it's just Kareem
abdul-jabbar as a co-pilot it is just so
well acted there's so many jokes it is
jam-packed with jokes airplane one of
the best comedies I've ever seen in my
life my personal favorite comedy growing
up was pee-wee's big adventure directed
by Tim Burton and I love this movie
because Paul Reubens is a he's just
brilliant plays this character pee-wee
Herman and the creativity that's put
into this movie it was like what else
can you add to make this movie just the
opening shot of him waking up and
there's like a Rube Goldberg contraption
of how he makes toast and breakfast in
the morning like he drops a ping-pong
ball it hits a candle that turns on and
burns a rope that breaks and swings a
hammer into it it was so creative I
remember being a kid I watched that
movie probably 300 times and memorize it
at least through the voice I just love
doing it
pee-wee Herman is brilliant it's for
kids but it's for adults he's just such
a good actor in this movie Paul Reubens
should have gotten an Oscar for this
pee-wee's big adventure it is
unbelievable and it's one of Tim
Burton's first films so if you're a if
you love movies and film and like Tim
Burton you don't want to miss this one
it's a classic all right this is a
comedy for the you movie nerds but
that's probably why you're on Rotten
Tomatoes anyway because you are a film
there but this movie is called American
movie and it's a documentary comedy and
man oh man I remember seeing this film
with Horatio Sanz we're in the theater
and we were crying so hard laughing we
were hugging each other and like
punching each other because we're
laughing too hard
it's about it a man trying to make a
horror movie and it's about a coven but
he doesn't like the way it coven rhymes
with evany that doesn't make sense we
calls it mispronounces it's the own
title for his film and calls a Kovan it
is it is all local actors he's trying to
get into this low-budget horror film and
there's so many great characters in it
he takes a dent at a local dentist actor
the dentist wants to be actor and he's
ramming his head into a closet that he
was supposed to have scored so that it's
easily breakaway but he forgets to score
the wood so he's actually ramming a
human's head into a wooden cabinet he's
screaming and he's ramming this poor
man's head into the thing so cutting the
guys like holding his head Oh God he's
like oh yeah I'm sorry I forgot to cut
that board should have break I should've
been trying to punch it to break it and
he still can't he's hurting his hand if
it's one of the best movies I've ever
seen it will make you cry laughing if
you love filmmaking you will appreciate
this and and the two guys the two stars
of the movie are true stars it's a
classic movie it's called the American
movie and it will make you laugh